معني قبل اقل من نصف ساعه من الان كانت
هنالك اشتباكات واستمعنا الى ذوي القذائف
والرصاص وربما المدفعيه اطلقت في عمق ما
تصل اليه الصوره الان الصوره الان تمضي
اللي تقترب اكثر من قاعده مروي العسكريه
هذه هي صوره لقاعده مروي العسكريه ولبرج
المراقبه ولمركز العمليه الحربيه العسكريه
التي بدات منذ الامس قبل نصف ساعه من الان
كانت تتمدد في وسط هذه الصوره اعمده
الدخان كانت تتمدد بشكل كثيف ومباشر في
مكانين من داخل هذه القاعده ويبدو ان
وتيره الاشتباكات عادت من جديد بين قوات
الجيش قوات الجيش المسلحه السودانيه وقوات
الدعم السريع يبدو ان المسار الان يمضي
نحو حسم هذه النقطه العالقه وجود قوات
الدعم السريع في هذه المنطقه تتمركز وسط
القاعده الى جانب احاطه قوات الجيش
احاطت
السوار بالمعصم لهذه القاعده ومنع قوات
الدعم السريع من الخروج المعلومات ايضا
تشير الى ان كلا الجانبين الان ربما يسعى
لايجاد مزيد من الدعم
وحشد لقوات عسكريه سواء كان من قوات الجيش
السوداني القوات المسلحه او من قبل قوات
الدعم السريع لحسم هذه الجزئيه المتعلقه
بوجود قوات الدعم السريع الداخل هذه
القاعده قاعده مروي العسكريه الان الترقب
يسيطر على المشهد الى اين ستمضي الامور
الاوضاع كلها الان مفتوحه على سيناريوهات
متعدده المواطنون يراقبون هذه هي مروي
بصورتها بوضعيتها الراهنه هاد هدات الامور
ولكن عادت مجددا قبل نصف الساعه الان
لنستمع الى صوت الاشتباكات لصوت الرصاص
وربما يتجدد خلال الدقائق المقبله لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقص ص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه
لا
تنسوا الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات